learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like search engine
marketing
strategies for paid campaigns analytics
Roi and evaluation and over a dozen
others and that's not all you also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in Top Tire product companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into a
digital marketing role as a fresher or
moved on to a higher paying job role and
profile if you are passionate about
digital marketing and want to make your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and description box to find a digital
marketing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest search
engine optimization we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you taken or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about about do follows
and no follows and and simply put I mean
do follows are just signals to the
search engines to follow the link so
there's a link on site a pointing to
site B we're going to basically tell
Google Bing and some of these other
search engines hey go ahead and follow
that link now a no follow is just the
opposite so no follow link doesn't allow
the search engine crawlers to follow it
so if we have a link on our site s site
a pointing to site B we can put a no
follow tab in there and what that's
going to do it's going to signal to the
Crawlers hey don't follow this link so
in the end if the Crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so Google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crop
to recognize those or not simply with no
follow text so just a reminder link ju
is the reputation or Equity pass from
one website to another so if you have a
link on another website and that website
is of high quality meaning their page
Authority their domain Authority is high
they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that site to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a no follow and why would
we do a no follow well it depends it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link juice on to
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision at the end of the day
there's really no hard fast rule here
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engines crawling
your site and they see that no follow
there they're not going to follow that
link and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the SE
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the key word here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just moved from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page anymore we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so if a 301 redirect
is permanent then a 3 302 is temporary
so we want the search engines to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
Google to not keep that page in its
search engine rankings because it's
temporary so why would Google want to
keep a temporary page or even a page
that is pointing to another page on a
temporary basis so they REM May remove
both pages from its index okay but if we
have something permanent in place Google
may say okay this page is permanently
linking to another page or redirecting
to another page therefore it's stable
it's permanent we're going to keep that
new page in the index and eventually
remove the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the no follow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and has a
high page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a Lon share of the
traffic for certain keywords that our
pages are found for and if our pages are
found and getting traffic then because
we have increased rankings we're likely
going to have increased traffic and then
it's just a snowball effect so more
traffic leads to more engagement and
conversions so the whole IDE idea for
SEO is remember you have an onpage
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
D domain Authority Google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank K we get more
traffic so it's a snowball effect so
having backlinks is important because it
snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for a web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know when you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake sake of the title they're going to
want to probably get a sneak peek via
the description of what it is so again
you want to optimize that description
but make sure the description is is just
as snazzy as the title okay you also
want to use accurate and relevant video
tags just as you would on Twitter or
Facebook tag these videos okay so make
sure your title tag length doesn't
exceed 100 characters because it will
get chopped off so again that goes back
to just writing something really short
and to the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you you optimized it feel
free to promote your video on other
social media platforms okay don't just
stick with YouTube per se so the benefit
here is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
going to like it and then other people
are going to see that engagement they're
going to see how many people liked it or
how many subscribers you have so promote
your videos to help you with the ranking
of the video on YouTube so that does
play into it so go ahead and promote it
so other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so if that smartphone
bot goes to your website and starts
crawling what do you think they're
looking for they're smartphone bought
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked this question you could even take
it a step further and say look I'm going
to measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bot and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who ask you this question because how
you going to know if one of your pages
is mobile friendly or not if you don't
look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mo mobile
usability report okay number six list
down the most important local SEO
ranking factors Okay so organic local
ranking is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say Google my business to
show up when somebody types in you know
looking for a florist or you're looking
for a coffee shop so what you want to do
is you want to create a web page for
every product and service and you also
want to opt for your business listings
on Google my business and and there are
plenty of other local business
directories out there like Yelp for
example or Bing even has one so go ahead
and also make sure you have a business
listing as well but since Google in the
United States has a huge market share
you want to start with Google first you
want to update your nap citations on
your website maintain consistency of
your nap okay so nap is name address
phone number so you want to make sure
that that's current and consistent so if
you have a number on your website make
sure it's the same number on Google my
business okay you can embed a Google map
on your website you could certainly
optimize the metatags and content not
only on your web pages but within your
Google my business directory so you can
add your business to other local
directories like I mentioned Yelp and
then also just as important opt for
reviews and ratings okay so the more
reviews that H you have the better off
you are okay so I always say this with
or with local search three of the main
factors in showing up for local search
on say Google is obviously the keyword
the second is the proximity of where
that person is and then third is the
reviews so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
key words let's just just say for your
product and service pages on your
website but also you can translate that
over to Google my business okay so
working in those keywords making sure
your your number your address your name
they're all consistent and and really
just spreading your the the business out
on other directories that's really all
these are really key factors for local
SEO okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this and
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember 301s
are permanent we can also use what they
call a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is op for
preferred domain in Google search
console okay so if you have multiple
domains make sure you set up a primary
one in search console so those are ways
to work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you could
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what is some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it it as simple as possible what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
and what do we mean by that well your
site's sitting on a server somewhere you
can own that server or you can be
renting it out from say Amazon web
services or let's just say GoDaddy as
your register they also have web hosting
well if you have it on say GoDaddy
server you may be sharing that server
with other businesses and at certain
times of the day other businesses may
get a lot of traffic and suck up a lot
of bandwidth what is that going to do
that's going to reduce the server
response time for your site and so you
want to make sure you have a an idea of
you know what's server your web page
your website is on and you want to be
able to can have some control over that
because if your server response is slow
that's going to slow down everything
else in terms of loading in the browser
and that's not going to be good for SEO
okay optimize your code we mean by optim
minifying when we say minifying we mean
get rid of some of the Redundant code if
you have CSS you know get rid of chop
some of the get rid of the JavaScript
you're not using so that's what we mean
by optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a cach
version of that page and then op for the
content delivery Network as well so
these are are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google's going to analyze the
URL for both mobile and desktop and so
here we could see Google gives the score
so we could see the score for mobile and
we could see the score for desktop just
by clicking on desktop and so here I can
see some of the issues that the site may
be having in terms of page low time for
their desktop if I flip over to mobile
you know here I could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specific
specifics here and or you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
the reduce the impact of third party
code okay so that's another thing uh
reduce JavaScript execution time so
again going back to a lot of some of the
comments we made about coding okay some
sometimes too much code or code not
functioning as well as it should will
tend to slow down the site okay so you
can use PP insights you can always get a
glimpse of how pages are loading simply
by also going to for example Google
analytics under Behavior okay you can go
to site speed and if you click on
overview okay Google what Google does is
they do a sampling of pages over time
and in this case based on 89 Page views
they have an average page load time and
so you can get a sense of how quick
specific Pages load your site overall
simply by looking at the site speed
overview report and Google analytics to
get a sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do affect load time so obviously the way
the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know co
uh Ivory Coast in Africa okay so it
really depends on the network you're on
so and also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings in Google analytics
and you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools that your dispos
proposal one Google analytics and one
page speed insights okay so let's look
at question number nine here so when
should an individual Target short tail
and longtail keywords okay so remember
short tail are usually one to two
keywords very Broad in nature longtail
keywords maybe three four keywords in a
query or maybe an entire sentence those
are considered longtail keywords so
usually short tail keyword have higher
volume but also higher competition
longer tail keywords usually have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about longtail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or Broad in nature
longtail keywords are used for targeted
Pages such as product pages and articles
so so if you have a specific product
with a long name you can certainly
optimize that page for that product name
again the product name may have low
volume but if somebody types in exactly
that product name you show up the chance
of you them converting are going to be
very high so you don't have to always be
that specific with a product name but
try and be as specific as you possibly
can in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say longtail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody ask me this question
in an interview what am I going to focus
on while developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and Ne easy for somebody
to find the the rule of THB is if it's
good for the end user probably going to
be good for Google go but if complicated
for the end User it's probably going to
be complicated for Google you always
want to create a sitemap now what is
that sitemap a Sit map is simply just a
formatted file with to that includes all
your URLs and assets your images and
your videos they're going to be sitting
on your server as well so you want
Google or these these Bots to be able to
find your pages and assets and by the
way you want to take it a step further
and make sure you upload that site map
which is sitting in the root directory
meaning
domain.com sitemap.xml okay you want to
take that sitemap and make sure you
input that sitemap location in Google
search console that way Google search
console has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a WIP side is having a
robot's text file and all a robots text
file is it's like a lock I always say to
a house so if you lock a door in your
house nobody's going to be able to get
in that door so it's all what robots
text file is you're telling Google and
these other Bots that are coming ACR
your site what's locked and what's not
locked meaning what they have access to
what they don't have access to so you
want to be able to make sure you've A
robot's text file if you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell Google don't crawl
these Pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
an indexed so there are a lot of reasons
to have robots text files that's the
main reason sit map you want Google to
get these pages and assets quickly okay
you want to make sure that your site
architecture navigation is in order you
want to make sure your site is mobile
friendly and you also want to make sure
you have content on your website that's
the key because that's what's going to
keep people on the website and engaged
and when I say content I don't
necessarily just mean words I also mean
videos I also mean images you know
something interactive okay you want to
keep people engaged that's the key
behind it trust me if if an end user
finds your site engaging Google is
likely going to find your side engaging
okay so those are good brownie points to
bring up if somebody asks you this
question in an interview so just a quick
cap here it's important to have a better
site structure so that Bots can easily
access and mix content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your s's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robots text just just
instructs the search engine crawlers to
understand what pages should not be
indexed okay this is simply just a text
file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
think give it that way okay so those are
our questions for SEO again if you have
any additional questions or if there are
other questions maybe you've been asked
in an SEO interview then go ahead and
add them to the comment section below
we'd love to hear from you now we're
going to turn our attention to search
engine marketing so let's turn our full
attention to search engine marketing so
we're moving away from SEO and over to
payperclick and so you really have to
know your stuff here you really do uh so
a lot of the questions we're going to
ask going to be centered around Google
ads formerly known as Google ads words
and so if you're familiar with Google
ads the platform then you should have no
problems whatsoever answering these
questions but that's why we're here and
that's why you're watching so there's
anything you want to add to any of these
questions as a reminder feel free to
comment under the video and so right out
of the gate question 11 what is AD
scheduling so ad scheduling is a feature
in Google ads and really all it does is
allow you the advertiser to set up
certain hours or days you want your ads
to show it's as simple as that so if you
have a customer that you're running ads
for on Google Search and let's just say
they have a restaurant and they're
closed During certain hours of the week
then you can go into the ad scheduler
and schedule your ads to not show when
they're closed as an example okay
because if somebody calls and they're
not there to answer the phone then it's
not going to be good for the restaurant
or you the advertiser and so that's why
they have the ad scheduling so it
ensures your ads are not running when
they're performing poorly let's just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you can serve your customers
when you do have limited client service
hours so let's just say you have a
customer service team that's going to
answer phones for a couple hours a day
well again you can schedule your ads to
show during those couple of hours a day
and then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you can satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of AD scheduling schedule
it according to the business hour
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're going to
have poor performance okay so next
question what are the different ad
formats available on Google ads it's a
trick question because it really does
come down to what network you're
advertising on so Google has two
networks the search Network and the
Display Network okay so on the search
Network there's only one ad format and
that's text okay so Google recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ADD extensions
and so you can see here underneath the
ad you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on a
headphones those are all site links to
specific pages on on the site so text
ads are available only on the search
network but they're also available on
the Display Network as well then you
have responsive display ads now
responsive responsive display ads are
only on Google's Display Network okay so
here you could see some samples of
responsive display ads and these ads
adjust their size and format depending
on the space available so again you can
have text ads or you can have display
ads Now display ads again come in
different sizes
so you can create ads you for a variety
of different sizes for example 250X 250
or 468 by 60 so those are some of the
different ad types there's there's an a
plethora of different ad sizes you can
choose however your ad's not going to
show on a website if they don't have
that particular size available so it's
always best practice to create different
ads but create ads in different sizes as
as well okay and then have a backup text
ad as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
Google will automatically show the ad
that's best performing based on a series
of headlines descriptions and images
that use you provide Google and so the
responsive part is hey if this
combination of headline description and
image work best meaning it has the best
click through rate then Google's going
to serve up that ad so that's why they
call it responsive so obviously you can
have just an image ad that's not
responsive again across different ad
sizes you know they could be again 250X
250 300 by 300 468 x 6 there's a number
of different sizes Google can provide
you that information but the one thing
to note here is that when you do create
an image ad it could be jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
PNG for example or it could be a static
or it could be interactive so definitely
take advantage of the different
opportunities uh meaning a static ad
versus an interactive ad you want to
have two variations of that so you could
see which one works best okay there's
also app promotion ads so these ads are
used to drive app download so you're
going to have to set up a campaign
accordingly okay but here you can see
this is what it looks like with a call
to action so it allows you to go ahead
and click and install that app so that's
an app promotion again if you have an
app and you want to promote it you can
use this type of AD format to align with
a campaign that's dro driving traffic to
download your app okay and of course you
have video ads well Google owns YouTube
and so if you have videos you have the
opportunity to advertise on YouTube okay
so these ads can be Standalone or
inserted into other streaming video
content and so To Me video ads work well
with specific strategies and what's one
strategy you would use a video ad for
brand awareness or education explainer
videos and so YouTube allows you the
advertiser the opportunity to get your
ad your service your product in front of
a lot of eyeballs so that's the beauty
of video ads they attract a lot of
eyeballs and definitely help with the
strategy of say brand awareness okay
another ad format going back to the
search network is shopping ads so if you
sell shoes then you may want to think
about having a campaign for shopping so
shopping ads work with Google Merchant
so Google Merchant is another Google
product and basically Google Merchant
allows you to manage your inventory so
if you have a hundred different types of
shoes that you're selling you can upload
your inventory to Google Merchant
connects and talks to Google ads so
basically what you're doing you're
setting up your your campaign in Google
ads and connecting your inventory from
Google Merchant to Google ads and so the
great thing about the shopping campaign
is it puts your product front and center
it puts the price it puts any promotion
that you have and it puts the brand all
front and center so when somebody does
type in let's just say lime green
sneakers or women's sneakers and this
particular shoe shows up here the third
one from the left then somebody's going
to see it's from the United Colors of
beniton it's a woman's shoe it's on
Amazon and it costs $45 so the great
thing about shopping ads is if
somebody's interested they're going to a
click okay if somebody's not interested
say well you know it's a little bit more
expensive I can get something similar
another shoe on Amazon for Less okay
they're probably going to click on that
particular ad so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search Network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so you can showcase your
shopping ads so these ads have an image
and a description that expand when
clicked so you can provide more
information more product and store
information as well you also have callon
ads okay so call only ads are enabled to
users to connect with your business
directly using the phone number provided
okay so it allows somebody on a mobile
phone who in this example is searching
for drywall repair well if you're in the
business of drywall repair you can have
your ad show up on mobile with the phone
number and somebody can easily click on
that phone number and just call you
directly now the way call only ads work
is you're still getting charged for the
click okay so anytime somebody clicks
and calls you're going to get charged
and you're going to get charged just as
you would if somebody clicked on your ad
so it's works the same way so it's a
cost per click again this is on search
so search is cost per click and the
beauty about call only is again you can
track the calls R in Google ads so you
can have Google ads track how many
people click on the number and you can
even count those calls as conversions if
they meet a certain criteria for example
the criteria is somebody talks to you
for a minimum of 60 seconds or 1 minute
then Google will count that as a
conversion so you can monitor calls
right in Google ads and it's a c per
click model so you can actually see what
the average cost per click is so moving
on question 13 okay what is rlsa and how
does it work well R LSA stands for
remarketing list for search ads so if
you're familiar with remarketing on
display it's similar they just call it
rlsa okay so it enables you the
advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you can tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
Google and search partner sites okay so
they're two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on Just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site key here is you're the one
that's picking the customer you're the
one that's enabling the list if you're
trying to Target people who went to your
site and didn't convert well you could
certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site and didn't convert or you
could set up a whole new campaign for
RSA and have a different set of keywords
with a different ad because you know who
you're talking to you're talking to
somebody who's already been to your site
they know your brand they just didn't
purchase and so this all happens on the
search Network and that's the beauty of
remarketing is one you know who your
audience is because you're the one
establishing that audience and two
you're the one creating the ad so you
can talk directly to that audience when
they see your ad again in this case on
search so that's rlsa remarketing list
for search ads I recommend pretty much
any industry any client any customer run
remarketing list for search advertising
and remarketing for display so those are
two key campaigns you should always
recommend running to a client because
one again you're defining the audience
two you're the one that's talking
directly to the audience because you
know who the audience is and three if
they see the ad and they click on it
again because it's cost per click then
the chances of converting are going to
be higher because they already been to
your website they know who you are and
so if they click on your ad again then
they must be interested so those are all
the benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn Google's
Display Network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have Affinity audiences so
basically Affinity audiences are
basically what are people's interest and
habits what do they have an affinity for
are there food sites travel sites
shopping sites fashion okay so that's
what Affinity really relates to okay
then you have in Market custom intent
life event these are what they're
researching or planning for so again it
could be travel it could be Finance Etc
okay you have remarketing we just went
over that with the remarketing list for
search advertising rlsa and so we when
the remarketing it's an audience that
has interacted with your website so they
either came from mobile or came from
mobile and didn't convert or female came
for mobile and didn't convert so you're
the one defining the audience there you
also have a similar audience so this is
what Google creates on your behalf so
these are users with a similar interest
to your site visitor so Google is
monitoring the type of traffic that's
coming to your site and based on that
traffic they're going to create a
similar audience and then you have a
custom match so what you know about your
customers activities basically so these
are all the different audience types and
you can see the different types of ads
available okay so notice the far right
column video ads so video ads are
available to every one of these audience
types why because YouTube so Google
knows what people's interests and habits
are based on the videos they watch they
know what they're looking for okay they
you know know that they've been to your
website because they're cookie so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in Google ads okay so this is a good
question very important if you're going
to manage a Google ads account and a
campaign you have to be aware of the
different match types you can't just go
broad match that's a sign of somebody
who doesn't know what they're doing is
by bidding on a one keyword phrase
that's a short tail keyword if you think
back to SEO we have our long tail and
our short tail keywords the worst thing
you could do is bid on a keyword short
tail keyword that's broad match because
what is Broad match basically broad
match ory keywords that appear when a
user searches any word in the phrase now
you can Define specifically what you
want your ads to appear for in terms of
keywords and when I say specifically you
can use a phrase match so phrase match
are ads that appear only when a user
searches for that exact keyword phrase
in the precise order but with some
additional words in the beginning or at
the end of the query okay so usually
these are sentences so you could be you
know bidding on red Adidas running shoes
and somebody could type in looking for
red Adidas running shoes in Portland
Oregon okay as an example okay so as
long as red Adidas running shoes are in
order in that keyword phrase then your
ad's going to appear because it's a
phrase match and then you can get really
specific by doing an exact match so
exact match or keywords that are
triggered only when that keyword and
exactly that keyword phrase is queried
so if you do an exact match for red
Adidas running shoes and somebody types
in only red Adidas running shoes then
that's an exact match and your ads going
to appear so let's take a look at these
again so you got broad match okay we got
a term cheap smartphone so if somebody
types in smartphone cheap phone smart
mobile phone cheap any one of those
combinations your ad's going to appear
now there's one thing you can do for
broad match and it's called broad match
modifier so you could put a plus sign in
front of the keyword for example let's
just say you really want to emphasize
the word cheap okay you're selling
really inexpensive smartphones okay not
just any smartphone but an inexpensive
smartphone so you can put a plus sign in
front of cheap and so somebody puts in
you know just smartphone or smart mobile
your ad's not going to show up because
the word the keyword query has to
contain sheet so anytime you put a plus
in front of the keyword query you're
bidding on then that means that keyword
has to be part of the keyword phrase so
that's a a broad match modifier if you
will and that prevents you from getting
unwanted Impressions so we have phrase
match again blue smartphone so somebody
could type in smartphone in blue color
cheap blue smartphone notice though the
second one where it says smartphone and
blue color your ad's not necessarily
going to show up because guess what blue
blue smartphone is the keyword query and
you're at your the query here is not in
that order so remember in order for you
to show up for phrase match the keyword
has to be in that order so I'm looking
for a blue
smartphone that is less than $100 okay
that could be somebody's query blue
smartphone was in that query in that
order so if somebody says looking for a
smartphone that happens to be blue less
than $100 then your ad is not going
going to show up so remember it has to
be in that ex precise order one thing I
want us go back to on the phrase match
notice that there's quotes around the
keyword anytime you see quotes around
the keyword that signifies it's a phrase
match because if we look at exact match
notice there are brackets around the
keyword red shoe that signifies is an
exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then you're signify
signaling to Google that this is an
exact match and I only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes Okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and Footwear
that's red is not going to work cuz this
is an exact match so you're saying I
only want to show up for the keyword red
shoe and Google recognizes plurals and
singulars together so somebody did type
in red shoes and your ad is going to
show up okay so moving on what are some
of the reasons as to why your ads could
have been rejected it happens to the
best of us and if you're writing ads and
they get rejected it could be for a
number of reasons so at the end of the
day you're violating Google's
advertising policies so some of the
policies that could have been violated
are and just some of the many we're just
listing some here prohibited content
prohibited practices restricted content
or editor and Technical so when you look
at prohibited content I will say say
this you're not going to be able to sell
drugs even if you're selling
pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so you're going to definitely
get flagged for that okay so there are a
lot of different ways in which your ads
can be disapproved okay but if you do
see restricted content then that means
you can advertise but with limited
limitations and usually those
limitations are restricted to say only
Google search and not Google search
Partners or to a specific geography so
usually the key here is if somebody
asked this question okay there are a lot
of different reasons Google's usually
going to provide the specific or the
reason why it got disapproved and
they're usually going to include a link
that you can refer to okay so at least
Google does that much they're not going
to leave you in the dark and tell your
add just been disapproved they're going
to tell you why and include a link that
you can go to figure out how you can
best resolve the disapproved ad so what
are the different kinds of bidding
available in Google ads so we already
covered part of this earlier on so
remember Google search network is only
CA per click CPC when we talk about
Google's Display Network you have three
options cost per click cost per view and
cost per impression and CPN is cost per
1,000 impression so you're paying per
1,000 Impressions impression is when
somebody actually sees your ad cost
preview is actually somebody looking at
your ad for at least 30 seconds or the
entirety of the ad so if the ad video ad
only runs 15 seconds and somebody
watched the entirety then you're going
to pay per cost per view so if your
video is 2 minutes long and somebody
watched 30 seconds you're going to pay
cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost preview again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1,000
Impressions so this the amount you pay
each time your ad is dis displayed in
the search Network and you pay for
Impressions that are generated for your
ad and you're paying for every 1,000
Impressions so the m is actually the nor
uh Roman numeral for 1,000 so that's
where the M part comes in so you're
paying for 1,000 Impressions so every
1,000 eyeballs you're going to pay a
price and so cost per impression is good
for brand awareness if you're trying to
generate a lot of eyeballs onto your
brand then you'd want to go with a CPM
model okay so question 18 what are some
automatic bidding strategies so let's
define automatic bidding strategy
automatic bidding allows Google take
over okay not you Google's taking over
and they're the one setting the bid
amounts automatically and it's going to
be based on criteria and some of and
that criteria is going to be centered
around conversions so if Google bids on
your behalf automatically basically what
they're doing is they're collecting data
on the behavior of your ads and so if
your ad is likely to get the click or
conversion then Google's going to set
the bid amount so you can win that
auction in order to get the click or the
conversion so they're different types of
bidding strategies but remember you have
to align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people to click on your ad and go to
your website then you're going to have
an automated bidding strateg of maximize
clicks that aligns with your campaign
strategy so this strategy automatically
sets your bids to help to get as many
clicks as possible within your budget so
Google is going to do its best based on
historical performance of The Campaign
to generate traffic to your site that's
the goal that's the biz strategy okay
let's take a look at some others so hey
the goal of our strategy campaign is to
increase visibility so that's an easy
one remember cost per impression
question s hey we want to maximize how
many people look at our ads okay so
Target impression share so this bidding
strategy allows your bids to show at the
top of the page okay so you're getting
the impression so people are able to
look at your ad okay so you're telling
Google hey I want to be shown at least
50% of the time when somebody types in a
keyword that I'm bidding on so they're
going to make sure that they meet your
target impression share 50% so they're
going to set your bids automatically to
make sure your ad shows at the top of
the page so it's seen at least 50% of
the time that's the goal of the campaign
that's the bidding strategy goal we set
up a campaign to drive conversions so
there are a couple bidding strategies
against conversions so Target CPA so
this strategy sets a search or display
bid to get as many conversions as
possible but there's a caveat here cost
per acquisition is what CPA stands for
so we're trying to get as many
conversions as possible but at a certain
cost for example if I'm selling T-shirts
for $10 do I want to pay $20 CPA for
every sale do I want to pay Google $20
no I'd be losing money i' be out of
business okay so if I'm selling T-shirts
for $10 on my website I'm probably going
to put the CPA about $2 or $3 again
depending on my cost of goods so if I
factor in my cost of goods I'm trying to
make a profit then I'm going to s Google
look I'm trying to get some sales but I
don't want to lose money getting the
sales so you're going to put in a
threshold and that threshold is your
target CPA and so Google's going to
automatically Bid and Win the auction
for keywords when they feel those
keywords can get you a Target CPA that
you put in for example $2 okay so the
goal of our campaign is to meet a Target
return on ad spend meaning return on
Advertising spend meaning we're getting
more Revenue than we're spend bending
that ratio needs to be positive so
Google's going to help us again adjust
our bids to make sure that our return on
Advertising spend meets our criteria so
we could put a roas at 100% 200% Etc and
Google's going to adjust our bids
accordingly based on the keyword that
they think will meet that criteria of
100% or 200% so that's Target return on
Advertising spend and that's there to
see if Google can help you generate a
profit so we have another campaign set
up we're trying to get more conversions
we have a budget we want to spend the
budget but we we want to get conversions
so this is a gimme the bidding strategy
here would be maximize conversions so
this strategy sets bids like all the
others it automatically is going to
adjust your bid that is Google it's
going to adjust the bid to help you win
the auction based on historical
performance so if a key word in
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe Google's
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question that you're going to get if an
interview asks you this question this is
what Google ads is all about quality
score so what is quality score so simply
put quality score is a score between 1
and 10 given to every keyword you've
been on and basically between 1 and 10
it's Bas Google's given you the score
the quality score of that keyword and so
how does Google come up with that score
between 1 and 10 well there's three main
factors here one is expected click
theough rate the second is AD relevance
and the third is landing page experience
so obviously a higher quality score the
better off you are okay a low quality
score it's not going to bode well for
you and so if you have a low quality
score Google actually will tell you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and I will tell you this
if I were to divide them up and 2/3
click through rate expected clickr rate
is more important than the other two so
that's about 2/3 of quality score and
expected click the rate is basically
Google saying look other advertisers
have bit on this keyword and their click
theough rate has been historically
around say for example 3% so if you
can't get 3% then your quality score is
going to suffer ad relevance is simply
does the ad or is the ad relevant to the
keyword you're bidding on likewise for
the laning page but the Ling page
experience a little bit more subjective
because the landing page has to load
well fast no popups no a lot of external
links nothing spamming no ads being
served up so a lot of factors in Ling
page experience Google wants to make
sure somebody clicks on your ad that
they're going to have a good experience
when they land on that page and so
quality score is so key here it is very
key because if you don't have a good
quality score the repercussion means
you're going to have to bid higher
because quality score times bid equals
add rank so for every auction Whoever
has the highest ad rank is going to be
at the top of Google search results so
if you have a low quality score let's
just say one and you're bidding $4 on
that keyword then your ad rank is four
one time 4 is four so you got to keep
that in mind because other advertisers
could have a higher ad rank or better
quality scores for that keyword so again
expect a click array this just shows How
likely it is that your ads will get
clicked when shown for particular
keyword Google expects a certain number
here you should always try to achieve
the highest click the rate possible and
click the rate is simply how many times
your ad was seen versus how many times
it was clicked that's all click the rate
is clicks divided by Impressions so you
should always try to achieve the highest
click there rate possible that will
avoid getting a low quality score add
relevance so add relevance simply means
how relevant is your keyword to the ad
okay so if you're bidding on Reddit deas
running shoes then make sure your ad
discusses and mentions multiple times
naturally red Adidas running shoes okay
and remember with those text ads you
have three headlines you have two
description lines of up to 90 characters
you have side extensions okay you have
path one and path two that meaning you
can add additional keywords to the end
of a URL so you have lots of
opportunities to make sure the ad is
relevant to the keyword and then landing
page experience again this is a little
subjective but hey he Google's going to
use landing page experience to estimate
how relevant and useful your website's
landing page will be to people who not
only click on your we land on that page
so does that page load fast does it have
any unnecessary popups does it does it
have some quirky external links that
look spammy okay you got to take all
these things into consideration and
think about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the Hallmarks of a good PPC
landing page so going back to Landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and Powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad they go to
landing page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and Powerful
headline should include that key word
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know complement the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough wi space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these Pages Via Mobile so you
got to take that in consideration as
well so cramming your pages full of
content videos and images is probably
not going to bode well so make sure
there's breathing room for people to
read understand and react and those are
Hallmarks of a good PPC Landing pitch
some other factors here adding trust
indicators like you some statistical
evidence meaning how many people
downloaded your app you can always have
testimonials you know thirdparty sales
of approval like Better Business Bureau
you know privacy policy links help okay
so you want to add some things in there
that's going to you know give you
credibility having a properly designed
lead capture form to collect visors
information is always helpful if you're
trying to get that conversion then have
a lead form make it simple don't have a
lead form with 20 forms or Fields you
know have a simple name email address
make the phone over optional and have
one feel that they can type in specific
information and then last but certainly
not least have a good call to action so
make sure that call to action aligns
with what you're trying to do again
selling those red Adidas running shoes
if they're on sale then you know make
sure the call to action aligns with that
sale you can always say you know 20% off
for the next two days or you know $10
off if you purchase today so have some
good strong call to action here we wrap
up at this video and if you have any
queries regarding any Concept in the
video feel free to add it in the comment
section below and our experts will be
happy to help you do subscribe to Simply
learn to stay updated with the new
technology Trends and thanks for
watching staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations
and delivered by industry experts choose
any of our programs and set yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here